(funky instrumental music)
- I just feel that I'm a person
that has something to say,
and instead of saying it and using words,
says it by just putting
some paint on a surface.
My name is Halwani, and I'm
a street artist from Beirut.
The reason I paint portraits
or figures that kind of show
our country is very simple.
When I started painting all over the city,
I used to have to remove
photos of politicians,
and political logos and election posters.
These politicians weren't
necessarily good at their job,
occupy most of the urban landscape,
and this is where I actually
wanted to replace them
with something more positive
that the citizens of Beirut,
that the presence of these
people is really optional.
There's a very complicated
question of identity,
when it comes to: what does
it mean to be Lebanese?
And this is another reason
why I paint these faces.
They represent the stories
of Lebanon, Beirut,
and the Arab world in general.
A mural can make a wall not only a wall,
but maybe something that creates
a relationship of people with
an element in the street,
and I think it kind of spreads positivity
and changes the perspective of people
from their everyday life.
I really appreciate the people
that compare me to Banksy.
I really appreciate Banksy's work,
and I think it's smart, it’s, uh, witty,
and he has a lot of credit
when it comes to the
global street art movement.
I don't paint just for
the sake of painting,
or for the sake of capitalizing
on a certain event.
I just paint when I feel
that I have something constructive to say.